дуже сумую Я сумую Мені б хотілося щоб
мої діти бачили бачили мій дім бачили
інжирові сади дідуся Артек Якщо я вам
зараз це розкажу Напевно ви Перестаньте
їсти ці вафлі багатьох випадках самі
винні що
втрачено було певний зв'язок з Кримом бо
ми його розглядали як базу відпочинку
накладаю собі вівсяну кашу А тут камера
РТР чи ОРТ просто лізе тобі
в обличчя а вони монтували начебто там
На моєму домі висить прапор Росії можна
сказати що в моєму першими слухачами
були барани ну же як є
сьогодні говоримо зі співачкою
переможецею Євробачення 2016 року
джамалою Добрий день Дякую що погодилися
на цю розмову одразу Хочеться привітати
вас із виходом нового альбому який має
назву Крим Наскільки я знаю не лише
вихід та й сама існування цього альбому
було під загрозою адже він потрапив в
підостріл у будинку звукозапису
Розкажіть будь ласка цю історію Знаєте
будь знаєте це така доля напевно вже і
самого альбому хрін ви кажете Крим а для
мене дуже важливо щоб ми навчилися
вимовляти назву цього альбому
склотарською тому давайте разом
грим-хрим чудово Виходить так вийшло що
22-го року
24 лютого коли почалася повномасштабна
війна
альбом хрим знаходився в будинку з
звукозапису
XXI року в вересні ми це все записали а
в запису приймала більше ніж від 80
інструменталістів народна група
величезна команда яка
працювала самому будинку і ви знаєте
Ніхто ж не думав не вірив і весь
матеріал терабайте пам'яті залишалися
знаєте як у відкритому комп'ютері в
якому триває процес це знаєш як ти
виходиш зранку там відкрив свій
комп'ютер там загрузив щось і пішов
робити свої справи От приблизно так це
відбувалося з альбом хрим 24 лютого і
другою моєю думкою після того де мої
діти
от Де мої діти старший якому три рочки
тоді Рахман спав дитячий а Селім якому
півтори рочки було
спав зі мною І от я їх
зібрала разом одягла теплий тепло і
після цього Я
зателефонувала Сергію крутенка який був
інженером запису і сам продюсером
альбомом
і кажу Серьожа все Що робити
Ми втратили альбом ми втратили просто
зараз потрапить туди
ракета і немає і немає нічого
він каже Ні ні ні я доберуся туди я його
збережу Я кажу ні Сергій я не хочу щоб
ти ризикував своїм життям
і ви знаєте
на сьогодні я можу сказати що
він справді ризикував своїм життям
він врятував альбом він його зберіг
через місяць він дістався і почав
збереження але в січні цього року Сергій
помер
бо його серце не витримало цього всього
Він дуже переживав за війну
і він для мене був тою людиною як до
якої їздив звернулась вперше взагалі
коли в мене виникла думка
зробити такий альбом
повірте мені в нас просто немає фахівців
в Україні на жаль які можуть записати
альбом такого масштабу і я без
перебільшення зараз це кажу бо записати
оркестр якісно потім зробити міксинг
мастирування
це
це неймовірна робота і це не просто
якась знаєте навіть технічно складна
історія це це правда
небагато фахівців які знаються в цьому
От Сергій був один з них
[оплески]
[музика]
Розкажіть будь ласка як зародилася ідея
створити цей альбом
можна сказати я так чи інакше
завжди жила З цією думкою Бо в моїх
авторських альбомах буцімто більш
електронних Соул поп
які я робила там за свою кар'єру якщо ви
помітите Якщо ви є моїм слухачом то
звернете увагу так чи інакше в мене
обов'язково була або пісня
кримськотарська Тобто це таке знаєте
логічне продовження От і Якби
я би не хотіла сказати що це там мій пік
чи щось таке але це
логічно продовження мене як музиканта як
співачки
і
ідея зарождалася давно а от три роки
тому можна сказати що я вже розпочала
роботу саме збирання матеріалу архівних
пісень да тобто в чому полягає ідея
хотілося
розказати піснями
про
історію цілого народу
і тут почалося найскладніше бо архівів
немає і тому я збирала ці пісні з різних
джерел Тут були і книжки і записи і
просто диктофоні записи Середньої Азії і
все виглядає так що це велика
дослідницька робота яка для вас відкрила
багато нового і про свій народ і про
себе правда Я сама відкрила багато про
про себе і свій народ і звичайно я не
історик Я не культуролог я не археолог я
співачка і музикант яка все життя
перебуваючи в Криму а потім там в Києві
я мріяла про те щоб таке зробити щоб все
більше людей дізналося про те наскільки
в нас красива музика Наскільки в нас
красива мова Наскільки в нас красива
теорія що давайте будемо відвертими щоб
що ми
в багатьох випадках самі винні що
втрачено було певний зв'язок з Кримом бо
ми його розглядали як базу відпочинку і
ніколи не розглядали як
неймовірно спадщину Свою ж це знаєте як
от прийти додому до себе і сказати Боже
це моя крісло Боже я так його люблю бо
воно моє
уявляєте собі який був би кайф якби ми
відносились так до кожного куточку своєї
землі в одному інтерв'ю ви сказали про
те що Крим це не лише про море і про
чебуреки А про що для вас Крим Ой він
настільки дивовижний Я не знаю ще до
кінця його на жаль на жаль коли я
закінчила
сімферопольське училище 17 років Я
поїхала в Київ то я приїжджала додому
все але все одно моє життя вже більш
вирувало тут і мені так шкода що я мала
подорожувала мала знала і але все що я
знаю На сьогодні це закладалося моєю
прабабусею на Зохан а бабусю едіє
дідусем а яром батьком алімом і багатьма
людьми з якими спілкувалися до нас
приходили музиканти в нас був інвери з
майлав з якими там могли вдома пограти
влітку і так далі І так далі знаєте Я
помітила коли ви говорите про Крим у вас
навертаються сльози
Я так розумію що вам це болить і Що вам
болить найбільше за Крим
дуже сумую Я сумую Мені б хотілося щоб
мої діти бачили Крим бачили мій дім
бачили інжирові сади дідуся
провідали могили наших предків
це дуже сумно Коли в сучасному світі
обмежують твою свободу а це не Свобода
на свободу поїхати туди де ти хочеш бути
жити і
Так я бачу Крим
вільним в якому живуть різні народи які
у вас найтепліший спогад про Крим
можливо з дитинства
з дитинства
ну В нас в сім'ї всі музиканти Мама грає
на фортепіано батько грає на акордеоні
співає пісня Алім
буде звучати з батьком його Так і звуть
Алім вона про історію аліма гайдамаха
який був на кшталт Устима Кармелюка
боровся з права знедолених
[оплески]
[музика]
дитинство було в музиці
батько співав мама грала бабуся робила
завжди
смачні страви крем скотарські я бігла
збирати спочатку
виноградні листочки знаєте вони такі
коли Зелені вони їх закриваєш банку а
потім взимку відкриваєш і робиш з нього
Сарма І от Це була моя завдання піти
зібратися цілій листя Потім
після школи в мене була 5 5 баранів яка
мала випасти їх а-а і от я коли виходила
співати виходила до баранів Я їм співала
виходила і там була така класна акустика
вот там
кучуку зенів в нас було Ну ти виходиш
там виноградники гори і от там вони собі
їли
А мені в цей час було нудно Я їм співала
пісень так що можна сказати що в моєму
першими слухачами були барани Ну вже як
є
і це був дійсно дивовижний спогад правда
я от зараз згадую і мені
не те що там не соромно але я просто
реально цим пишаюся Бо це така моя
дитинство яке було сповнене Саме
таких таких
вражень да
А на вашу думку чому в Україні у світі
так мало знають про Крим справжній Крим
про кримських татар Чому так сталося бо
ви знаєте мені здається що
Російська імперія спочатку а потім
Радянський Союз вкладав дуже багато
грошей щоб
породити якісь міфи про Крим щоб зробити
цю колоніальність і замінити значення
тобто що я маю на увазі в нас
з'являється
не ханський палац або там я не знаю
харособазарі Ці скелі і так далі а в нас
з'являється
лівадійський дворец так потім там
тропа Галіцина
там Пушкін писав не Коцюбинський в
кучукозені написав свою одну з видатних
книг
Розумієте це ж факт історичний А ми його
не знаємо а ми знаємо точно що там є
ласточки над гніздо і оці історії Бо
більше того
Артек Якщо я вам зараз це розкажу
напевно використання їсти ці вафлі саме
Артек - це арт арт-етик це біля підножі
біля гори бо це біля аюдагу
гора
Ведмідь яку ми знаємо да аю-дах І там
були селища кримських татар біля більше
ніж
120 сімей там проживала так от я вам
скажу що їх всіх зібрали
погрузили і вигнали А це місце отак
зруйнували і побудували там
Артек який ми знаємо що це дружби там
народів чи як він там себе позиціонував
і от Чому знову ж таки Чому мала знала
бо ті діти які приїжджали в аптеці а їх
були
тисячі мільйони
тепер Ці діти вони виросли і вони можуть
бути
там в Кенії Америці в Європі
і в них вже залишилась Ця історія
пов'язана з їх дитинством як з Кримом
який був начебто російський
і тому так дуже важко працювати саме що
стосується Криму або
дуже багато було
грошей туди
вложено щоб зруйнувати справжній Крим чи
залишаються у вас у Криму зараз друзі
знайомі рідні як Вони переживають
окупацію важко важко всі переживають але
тримаються
І знаєте Я ніколи не дозволяла собі
засуджувати людей які залишилися або які
не мали сил
кожен день бути під наглядом прослушкою
пресінгом
залишатися там
Я з повагою відношуся до тих людей і
вдячна зараз за кожен
супротив який там відбувається А ми
бачимо що він відбувається кожен день і
ці люди для мене справжні герої І в
своїй творчості говорите про кримських
татар про своє коріння про свій народ
на Євробаченні Ви також перемагали з
піснею 1944 про депортацію кримських
татар у 1944 році за наказом Сталіна
Розкажіть будь ласка чому для вас
важливо в своїх піснях говорити про
трагедії свого народу розповідати про
свій народ Бо я з цим
живу кожен день А мені здається
будь-що ти робиш Головне щоб це було
правдою і щирим якщо тобі це не
подобається Якщо ти це не любиш Краще не
роби
картина не знаю одяг все що нас пов'язує
це має бути зроблено з любов'ю я роблю
це З любов'ю я
щиро
надихалася своєю прабабусею коли писала
пісню 1944 бо вона була в мене перед
очима бо вона для мене була
символом сміливої жінки яка не побоялася
і виростила чотирьох синів і втратила
доньку в вагонах товарних вагонів А ми
знаємо що
ця депортація це було абсолютно вбивство
бо якщо в цьому вагоні без їжі без води
без повітря вони їхали до Середньої Азії
майже там
100 людей доїжджало 20 максимум Ну то Ну
і вона це все пережила і для мене була
символом того що це ми жаліємо що нам
важко
А як мої батьки і поверталися в Крим не
маючи Юності не маючи молодості Вони все
поклали задля того щоб повернутися саме
в Крим і тому я з цим жила
давайте згадаємо фінал Євробачення 2016
року тоді до останнього була така
інтрига Хто переможе ви чи представник
від Росії Сергій Лазарєв що відбувалося
поза камерами чи взагалі ви відчували
якесь негативне ставлення з боку Росії
російської команди тому що в цій команді
був відомий прихильник Путіна Філіп
Кіркорова о повірте мені це була ще те
завдання з зірочкою бо вони мене
діставали просто на сніданку коли я там
в 7 годині на стою там
накладаю собі вівсяну кашу А тут камера
РТР чи ОРТ просто Еліза тобі в обличчя і
вони ночували
вдома перед моїми батьками вони
пролізали через забори а вони монтували
начебто там На моєму домі висить прапор
Росії вони дуже багато грошей вклали щоб
зробити все можливе і неможливо щоб мене
дискваліфікували з конкурсу бо вони
зібрали комусь і комісію яка мала
довести що пісня політична вона
розбирали лірику з цієї пісні вони
присвятили там говорити ж Как там у них
это передача Говорить Малахов Чи якось
там присвятили мені передачу а вони
розбирали що я там а-а взагалі не
дівчина чоловік ми тепер то розуміємо що
їх абсурд з пташками які наколені там чи
що в нас там постійно кожен день якась
нова супер новина от ми тепер бачимо що
е-е в них немає меж для того щоб
брехати брехати брехати все тому Да Було
важко моїй сім'ї мама після цього на
жаль
в неї дуже погіршили здоров'я вона зараз
в неї проблеми з серцем не вона інсуліну
залежна і це все це все моя Перемога на
жаль
На жаль я маю це визнати і мені дуже
соромно що з одного боку я правду борюся
а з іншого Я розумію що це не проходить
Просто так А як ви оцінюєте пісню
цьогорічних представників від України на
Євробаченні гуртотворчій Мені
подобається і творче і пісня І взагалі я
вважаю нам нема чого хвилюватися бо ми
зараз отримали навіть більше ніж можемо
в ті часи Ми отримали українське
Євробачення а в супер музичній країні
Ліверпуль Все для всіх хейтерів хто там
щось якось хоче сказати Ну це просто ви
навіть не розумієте масштаб того що ми
отримали зараз бо кожен день от Я
наприклад на своєму
графіку бачу що кожен день 6 по 14 В
мене є події яка саме про Україну
та Україну в Україні і так далі І так
далі Тобто Ну я кожен день кожен день Як
ви гадаєте наскільки можливо що Україна
переможе другий рік поспіль адже такі
випадки в конкурсі були наприклад
Ірландія перемагала кілька разів поспіль
І чи взагалі треба нам це перемога зараз
ви згадали Ірландію А я зі свого боку
згадаю Ірландію
Ірландія дуже багато прийняла українців
зараз і дуже підтримує і коли я їхала на
зустріч з президентом Америки я нас
на свій
своєму стиду дізналася що
байдений Ірландець Чому він настільки
розуміє нас і чому саме він навіть
правильніше казати не цілу Америка Там
нас всіх підтримає а саме байде нас
підтримує бо він як Ірландець як що
розуміє наш обід і за що ми боремось бо
як знову ж як цей склався цей пазл бо я
їхала нагороджувати гурт YouTube яке є
ірландським гуртом вони були з
пропорцями і те що їх нагороджував
Байден Я пам'ятаю що от бонас був дуже
схвильований пишався цим і я мала за
честь виступати в Кеннеді Холі закривати
кеннедіцентр Уно церемонію піснею
YouTube для YouTube коли були присутні
Ентоні блінкін Байден Ненсі полосі
віце-президенти і всі мала зустрічі з
ними І от оце знову не перемога важлива
Я не знаю переможець вони не це вже мені
взагалі не цікаво цікаво наскільки ми
зараз
отримаємо цього інформаційного простору
розумієте бо це дуже важка праця Тим
паче тримати на собі увагу вже більше
ніж рік після початку повномасштабної
війни я можу сказати на своєму прикладі
Ось що от мені дуже допомогли
саме посольство Германії і Швейцарії щоб
реалізувати саме альбом грим на сцені
Києва а для мене це теж дуже важливо щоб
саме Києві була перша презентація Бо для
мене це такий знов інформаційний знак
світу Що дивіться попри обстріли поки я
не можу зробити це в Криму ми робимо це
в Києві відразу після нападу Росії на
Україну ви почали активно збирати кошти
на підтримку України видавали концерти я
наскільки розумію ви були однією з
перших артисток то почав цим займатися
скільки загалом вдалося зібрати за понад
рік діяльності знаєте
Мені дуже пощастило що в мене немає
фонду Тобто я не Сергій Притула Я
намагалася співпрацювати з різними
фондами який брали на себе саме оцю
фінансову відповідальність бо я в даному
випадку тільки Інструмент я виходила Я
говорила Я співала
Так я витратила на це рік свого життя
Хто з цього більш постраждав звичайно
мої діти вони мене не бачили на жаль
але
але все одно
це скільки ми зібрали оці різні фундації
з якими співпрацювали це це неймовірні
гроші
це більше ніж 90 мільйонів євро це
це гроші які були спрямовані
на різні потреби України
Діти
військові медичну допомогу і так далі І
так далі І кожен раз коли я просто
знаєте от сідала в літак міняла локацію
і просто отримувала СМС подяки від
організаторів
ми зібрались тільки стільки і я там вже
робила там пост в Інстаграмі звитувала
своїм підписникам що от бачите от
Сьогодні ми тут заспівали зібрали там 50
тисяч євро тут ми 80 зібрали а тут ого
Ми зібрали там 14 мільйонів і так далі І
так далі Ну тобто Це мене дуже надихало
і кожен раз коли я чула що
збіри Люди приходять зараз зараз важче
зараз я думаю що всі музиканти які
продовжуються шлях набагато важче бо
треба якось я навіть на танці пішла на
танці пішла бо вже по відчувала
трохи таку
зменшилась саме оця позиція благодійних
концертів і я думала Чим ще можна
продовжити оцю увагу тримати і в цей
момент польські танці запропонували мені
піти на Танці з зірками я точно сказала
Ні ви що які танці а потім вони сказали
а якщо ми будемо збирати таку гроші а ну
якщо бути збирати гроші тоді давайте
це дуже отака Ну а що робити бо я
реально розуміла що
треба якось змінювати тоді
не знаю навіть жанр Окей я співачка Окей
буду танцювати Добре зараз Україна і
світ в очікуванні контрнаступу і багато
розмов Ми чуємо останнім часом ми про
деокупацію Криму але для вас остаточна
перемога України у цій війні це
деокупований Крим Звичайно
це така помилка яка ми допустилися на
початку 14-го року на жаль ми не
докричалися до світу що це біда нам
казалося що це пів біди А це була біда
біда яка була перед носом і ми її не
побачили і тепер ми маємо і тому я думаю
що на цей раз ми не маємо дозволити
відхапати в нас частину і сказати що так
і було Ну от
не маємо права на це не маємо права
здатися треба йти до кінця я дякую вам
за цю розмову і бажаю Успіху вам і
вашому альбому хочеться щоб його почули
якомога більше року слухайте і будьте
підтримувати всю культуру України Таким
чином Дякую вже